wird jetzt planet 9 gefunden ganze 139
bislang unbekannte himmelskörper konnten
jetzt am rande des sonnensystem
aufgespürt werden
ausschau gehalten die fachleute
eigentlich nach dem hypothetischen
planet 9 und diesen könnten sie mit
einem neuen suchverfahren jetzt auf die
schliche kommen klicks um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
und nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen der äußerste
bekannte planet des sonnensystems ist
neptun denn pluto hatte 2006 jahr den
planeten status aberkannt bekommen
diese entscheidung hatte damals für sehr
viel aufregung gesorgt doch es ist so
wie es ist und jenseits der bahn
vernetzung beginnt damit der sogenannte
kuiper gürtel
dabei handelt es sich um eine region in
der fachleute weltweit zigtausende
objekte mit achtung mehr als 100
kilometern durchmesser vermuten ebenso
wie viele weitere kleinere brocken
allesamt überreste aus der frühzeit des
sonnensystems den kupfergürtels kann man
sich wie eine ringförmige zone am
außenrand unseres sonnensystems
vorstellen doch diese sogenannte
transnet ton ischen objekte sind super
schwierig aufzuspüren denn sie befinden
sich ja jenseits von neptun und sind
extrem licht schwach da kommt nicht mehr
viel ich von der sonne an dazu kommt
dass sie sich auch nur sehr langsam
bewegen und somit sind sie für unsere
teleskope kaum zu identifizieren
dazu sagt der us astronom gerry byrne
style wie viele transnet tun ja man
finden kann hängt davon ab wie groß der
himmels ausschnitt ist und wie dunkel
das licht schwester objekt ist dass man
gerade noch erkennen kann es ist zum
haareraufen denn im kupfergürtel könnte
sich auch der mysteriöse neunte planet
verbergen dieser könnte möglicherweise
ähnlich groß sein wie neptun doch seine
existenz ist umstritten der große
wettstreit um diesen möglichen neunten
planeten unseres sonnensystems ist
bereits vor jahrzehnten entbrannt
forscherteams weltweit jagen das phantom
und jeder will der erste sein
verschiedene anhaltspunkte für planet 9
haben forschungsteams bereits gesammelt
mal mehr mal weniger stichhaltig dadurch
ist ein relativ konkretes bild von
diesem mysteriösen riesenplaneten der
sich wohl irgendwo in unserem
sonnensystem versteckt hält
bei planet 9 handelt es sich nach
meinung vieler forscher
entweder um einen gesteinsplaneten mit
dem vierfachen er durchmesser und einer
masse die maximal zehn mal so groß ist
wie die der erde ein gigantischer
brocken also um es mal auf den punkt zu
bringen berechnungen legen nahe dass er
wohl 10 bis 20 tausend jahre braucht um
die sonne in einer langgezogenen
umlaufbahn zu umrunden
ein us forschungsteam hat jetzt eine
super aufwendige studie gestartet und
dabei auf eine gigantische
himmelsdurchmusterung zurückgegriffen
es handelt sich um die daten der
sogenannten dark energy server des diese
astronomischen beobachtungen werden dem
optischen und nahe infraroten
spektralbereich durchgeführt mit am
start eine 520 megapixel kamera die auf
ferne und lichtschwache objekte
spezialisiert ist im visier der
fachleute die daten aus insgesamt vier
jahren und die enthaltenen achtung mehr
als sieben milliarden schwache
lichtpunkte für das astronomie team also
eine riesige herausforderung denn hier
galt es zunächst alle objekte
herauszurechnen die von vornherein nicht
als transnet komische objekte in frage
kommen doch selbst nach dieser ganzen
arbeit blieben noch unfassbar viele
potenzielle kandidaten übrig nämlich 22
millionen
so musste also weiter ausgesiebt werden
in die engere wahl kamen objekte die
mehrere nächte hintereinander präsent
war wichtig auch wieder analyse die
position der objekte und wie sich diese
zu verschiedenen zeiten verändert monate
lang dauerte diese arbeit doch am ende
hat sie sich gelohnt übrig blieben
zunächst nur noch 400 potenzielle
transnet tun ja im letzten schritt
wurden diese dann noch darauf hin
untersucht wie sich ihre positionen über
längere zeiträume unterscheiden
das wurde dann mit den daten anderer
bereits bekannter transnet typische
objekte verglichen letztendlich blieben
dann insgesamt 316 objekte übrig die
eindeutig als translate unia
identifiziert werden konnten darunter
139 bislang völlig unbekannte manche der
identifizierten objekte befinden sich
weit vom bluetooth umlaufbahn entfernt 7
transnet tun ja befinden sich bis zu 250
mal weiter von der erde entfernt als die
erde also 250 astronomische einheiten
einige aber bewegen sich
auch innerhalb der umlaufbahn von pluto
das os forschungsteam ist optimistisch
zeitnah weiter erfolge vermelden so
können bis zu 500 weitere brocken wollen
sie aufspüren hinweise auf die existenz
eines neunten planeten hat die aktuelle
analyse allerdings nicht gebracht doch
das schließt seine anwesenheit auch
nicht aus dazu heißt es in der studie
dank dieser vorgehensweise könnten wir
auch der entdeckung von planeten näher
kommen ist planet 9
ein schwarzes loch anklicken anschauen
und klicks um science-fiction abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran